[موسيقى]
من مصر مشاهدينا سالنا الناس متى تقول
المصارع الهارب لتقنعه بالعوده الى مصر
خلينا نشوف شو
[موسيقى]
ارجع الرجوع هيكون احسن بكتير قوي حياتك
طول عمرك بره مش مش البطولات او الامبين
اللي انت هتحب تخشها دي الحاجه اللي
هتخليك مرتاح بعدين لا رجوعك هو اللي
هيريحك وسط اهلك واستناسك فينا بيبقى نفسه
اللي هو يحترف بره ويكون فرصته احسن عن
هنا بس هي الفكره كلها في الطريقه مثلا مش
كويسه مش مناسبه يعني كان ممكن يحترف احسن
من كده بيفكر يفكر اخده ولما يرجع ما اظنش
مشكله هتبقى كبيره ممكن يقدر يحلها تاني
ويطلع بطريقه تانيه مشرفه تشتغل في البلد
ومصر
لان اكيد فرصته ببرده وهنا احسن
وهو هناك اكيد الحياه مش هتبقى كويسه طبعا
زي هنا بالظبط لو كان شايف تقدير هنا في
بلده اكيد يعني ما كانش ما كانش ماشي بس
برضه في نفس الوقت احنا مش عايزين نشجعه
ان هو يمشي عشان دي بلدنا المفروض كلنا
واحد هنا وبنحبها
وكلنا برده في نفس الوقت بنقوم بيها
فالرساله المفروض تتوجه للشخص الاصلي
اللامشاه
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بحضرتك يا فندم اه والله اللي
حدث ان الواد بغدوده من الولاد المميزه
جدا ولد مؤدب ولد محترم كان موهبه يعني
كان موهبه متطلع لها انها تبقى موهبه معنا
كبيره ان شاء الله في المستقبل احنا
الفتره اللي فاتت ديت يمكن حصل تعديل كتير
قوي في بالنسبه للاعيب المنتخب كلها
وبدانا نحط مرتبات وبدانا نعمل لهم
معسكرات واعداد كويس قوي واضح من افضل
الفترات اللي فاتت ديت بس هو حصل لبس في
موضوع طبعا والده ان الفلوس اللي خدها
واتخصم منه الكلام ده كله طبعا يعني ايه
لبس
يعني ايه لابس ايه اللي حصل بالظبط في سوء
تفاهم يعني انه لانه الحديث عن انه
راتب سته اشهر يبلغ 18,000 جنيه
خصموا منه 14,000 يعني ايه ال 2,000 دول
اللي ولا ولا 4000 يبقوله يعني لا لا هو
اقول لحضرتك على حاجه احنا احنا عندنا
الفئات اللاعبين في الفئه الاولى 8000
جنيه الفئه الثانيه بيبقى 3000 جنيه
باخدوده كان من الفئه الثانيه لانه ما
كانش لحد وقتنا هذا حصل على ميداليه ذهبيه
للكبار في افريقيا والفئه الاولى بالنسبه
لنا هم ابطال افريقيا للكبار
لما احنا كنا طبعا مديني وعد انه بعد
البطوله دي ان شاء الله كل اللي هيجيب اول
افريقيا هيتحط في الفئه الاولى طبعا الولد
كان في حاجه اسمها رسوم انتقال هو كان
منتقل من من دي من الهيئه الهيئه تانيه دي
لها رسوم انتقال الرسوم كانت مقدره بحوالي
12,000 جنيه بالنسبه لبغدوده طبعا احنا
كسبت ليه احنا مش مش يعني مش هنخليك تدفع
المبلغ دوت احنا هنديك المستحقات ماليه
ومن اول مستحقات ماليه نبقى نخصمها منك
يبقى انت كده ما دفعتش المفروض ان الفلوس
دي بتدفع قبل انتقاله بس احنا الولد
حوالينا نعمل معاه اكسبت كويس شويه ان
احنا نعمله ده عشان ما يدفعش من جيبه طبعا
الولد لما جه اول مستحقات ماليه كان اول
ست شهور له ب 18,000 جنيه طبعا خصم منه
الضرائب العاديه خالص اللي بتقسمها الدوله
اللي هي ال 10% كسب عمل و3% ضريبه وده
حاجه زي كده يعني قوانين رولز معينه ات
منه بقى النسبه بتاعه الانتقالات بتاعته
اللي هو كان المفروض يسددها واحنا ما
تدخلناهوش يسددها في بدايه الانتقالات
يعني عملنا له تاجيل لها شويه هو ده
المفروض انه كان هيرجع كان هيرجع من بطوله
افريقيا ديت اتحرقت الفئه الاولى بتاعنا
وكان ياخذ له ست شهور كمان هياخدهم كاملين
بدون اي استقطاعات او خصومات طيب دلوقتي
ايه الموقف يعني يعني حضرتك بتقول احنا
وعدنا وقلنا له بس ترجع وبالتالي
الرجل لم يرجع بل ذهب الى الى فرنسا الان
ما الذي سيعيد الى مصر مره اخرى
والله يعني اللي هيعيده طبعا مسرح مصر
فيها ابطال كتير قوي في مصر فيها لعيبه
كتير قوي ولاده والولد من الناس المؤدبه
والمحبه اللي احنا كنا بنرعاها بنحترمها
طبعا بعد جهاز السيد مع رئيس الجمهوريه
برعايته ورعايه كل ابطال اللي زيه يعني هو
امبارح الرئيس مش وجه برعايه بغدوده بس
كمان ده قال لك اي زي بغدوده ومحتاج رعايه
ده هيتعارف هيترعى اتفضل دكتور مهو ربما
هذه هي المشكله بانه لماذا يجب الامور ان
تصل الى حد انه يهرب يهرب احد الرياضيين
اللي انتم متوقعين اله مستقبل وهو على
كفاءه عاليه حتى يتم الاعتناء بالرياضيين
في مصر هل هناك تقصير في دعم هؤلاء
الرياضيين ماديا وبالتدريب رغم انه هناك
مواهب كبيره نتحدث عن 120 مليون
مصري اكيد في مواهب بالملايين
والله هقول لحضرتك على حاجه احنا في
الفتره ديت وكان من ازهر فترات اللي
بتعيشها العاب الفرديه بنلاقي دعم مادي
ومعنوي كبير قوي من اجهزه الدوله من وزاره
الشباب والرياضه وللمبيه المصريه مش عايز
اقول لحضرتك احنا بدانا ناخد مكانش في
حاجه اسمها مرتبات للعيبه كانوا بياخدوا
مصروف جيب في المعسكرات الداخليه عاديه
النهارده بدانا نحط ليفل للمرتبات وكان
الليفل ده قابل للزياده احنا بدانا بدانا
الخطوه بشكل كويس قوي وبدا يبقى في رعايه
كويسه قوي كل ابطال البغدوده احنا عندنا
ابطال كتير قوي عندنا كيش وعندنا عبد
اللطيف اتفضل يا دكتور دلوقتي الدول
الاخرى والدول الاوروبيه التي تبحث حتى عن
محترفين للتميز ومشاركه هؤلاء المواهب
تعطيهم ما يفوق ايضا ربما الامكانات التي
موجوده في الدول العربيه لا اتحدث فقط عن
مصر اتحدث عن كل الدول الافريقيه
والاسيويه وكذلك العربيه
المغريات كبيره جدا يا دكتور محمود وانت
تعلم ذلك
طيب شكرا اكيد طبعا بس كل واحد بيبرر
هروبه من وجهه نظره هو لا هو ايضا ربما
ايضا طيب هذا الموضوع ربما مرتشعه في
الايام القادمه دكتور محمود السيد مدير
عام او سكرتير عام الاتحاد المصري
للمصارعه شكرا جزيلا لك لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات